atheism is a joke with no punchline told
by a comedian who's about to get booed
off stage some of you are too young to
remember atheism before the circus
clowns took over and spray painted the
new atheism down the side of that crazy
train but believe it or not atheists in
the 1980s and 199s weren't nearly as
angry as they've been in recent years
and they didn't usually care a whole lot
about what other people believed the
general atheist attitude when I was
growing up was look if believing in
Jesus and the Bible and Heaven somehow
helps you I'm not your boss you have fun
in church and go ahead and say a prayer
for me if that makes you happy what do I
care there were of course some
aggressive atheists the kind that made
people wonder how are these guys so
perpetually raged at someone they don't
believe exists but there were barely
enough of them to be
annoying atheists back then got along
with Christians they had friendly
conversations with Christians they
didn't lose their minds whenever anyone
disagreed with them about anything they
didn't spend every waking moment posting
Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy
Sky daddy in fact if you're an atheist
today and you were somehow able to jump
into a time machine fueled by 1.21 jerk
AWS of narcissistic personality disorder
and you traveled back in time to
1985 and you told an atheist from
1985 that in the future atheists are
going to spend all their time on social
media typing Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky
daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy that 1985
atheist is going to ask you what social
media is and then he's going to throw
his Dungeons and Dragons dice right in
your face tell you to get a
life so what happened to atheism who fed
that cute little mugw after midnight and
then poured Miracle Grow and Red Bull
all over the
gremlin I'll tell you exactly what
happened and once you understand the
rise of the new atheism you'll see why
its run is coming to an end and why
Christians are about to have not one but
two fun new arguments against atheism so
let's discuss the new atheism's
explosive growth since the early 2000s
its failed predictions our fun new
arguments and the future of
atheism why did the new atheism become
so popular after the 9/11
attacks three reasons first westerners
were jolted out of their tolerant
Slumber by a series of attacks carried
out by people screaming Allah abbar the
new atheists used these attacks to say
see this is what religion does science
flies you to the Moon religion flies you
into
buildings but they didn't just send
people into a panic over Islam they also
said and don't think that other
religions are much better Christians are
about to elect leaders who are going to
impose Christianity on the rest of us
Christians are about to use democracy to
end science and to establish a Christian
theocracy and the only way to stop it is
for millions of people to leave
Christianity and become atheists so the
new atheists saw that people were
alarmed they used that alarm to send
people into a panic about religion in
general second the emergence of social
media allowed the new atheists to use a
certain low-level manipulation tactic on
a global scale what's the manipulation
tactic something we've seen over and
over again in various forms for many
centuries the basic formula is join this
group and you're better than everyone
else in some significant way we see this
constantly from the dawa gangs their
message is if you join Islam you're
strong if you don't you're weak look at
us we're strong other people are little
weaklings the new atheist s did the
exact same thing but their message was
if you join us you're smart if you don't
you're a stupid relard what do you want
to be a super smart atheist or a super
dumb relard you want to be smart great
then join us and you can make fun of
religious people and feel smart you can
even come to the next reason rally where
we sit around and Pat ourselves on the
back for being so into science
this is pathetic but the movement had
the advantage of social media they got
to use this approach on billions of
people and millions of people fell for
it we want to be smart so we'll join
your group what do we have to do now oh
just just spend every waking moment
making fun of people with Sky daddy Sky
daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky Daddy and
that makes us smart yeah that makes you
smart sure does doesn't
it third because of the first two
factors panic and manipulation the new
atheism became what we might call
Evangelical atheism there was a strong
emphasis on winning converts not all
ideologies strive to convert people
Christianity does Islam does atheism
didn't much until the new atheism took
over over then atheists became obsessed
with getting the entire world to agree
with them which really makes no sense
from an atheist perspective Christians
proze because these are matters of
Eternal significance in Christianity
Muslims prze because these are matters
of Eternal significance in
Islam why would atheists suddenly care
so much about convincing everyone to
agree with their world
view well if atheism is the only thing
that can save the world from religion
then salvation is found only in atheism
so preach brother Dawkins preach brother
Hitchens preach brother
Harris atheism became
Evangelical they promised a kind of
Salvation the salvation of the world and
by taking advantage of people's growing
concerns over religion and using social
media to amplify a simple manipulation
tactic millions of people joined the new
atheism but there were three problems
which led to the eventual decline of the
new atheism first the new atheists had
an absurdly simplistic view of the world
religion is bad so get rid of religion
it rarely cross their minds to have a
deeper understanding of the various
roles a religion plays in a society
the closest parallel I can think of to
this simplistic thinking is in the realm
of ecology ecology is the science that
deals with connections among living
organisms and between organisms and
their
environments here's how stupid human
beings are a human being will move to a
place that has no rabbits and say to
himself you know what this place needs
some rabbits rabbits would be fun to
shoot then he'll bring in some rabbits
this sort of thing has happened
repeatedly in human history but right
now I'm thinking of Thomas Austin
bringing European rabbits to Australia
in
1859 he thought rabbits would be fun for
him and his friends to hunt in Australia
and they were so what's the problem well
rabbits had no natural predators in
Australia rabbits reproduce very rapidly
and many areas of Australia have
moderate climates that allow rabbits to
reproduce year round the rabbit
population exploded so quickly that
within 10 years Hunters could kill
millions of them every year without
noticing any effect on the rabbit
population rabbits would invade an area
and eat up all the vegetation massive
loss of plant species then the other
animals that normally ate those plants
wouldn't have any food they couldn't
compete with the rabbits so loss of
animal species rabbits would so
thoroughly devastate all the vegetation
that the top soil would be exposed to
wind and water erosion so plants
couldn't even grow back it was an
ecological
disaster what caused it rabbits not
really superficial thinking caused
caused the
disaster notice rabbits would be good
for hunting so let me bring some rabbits
here simple thought how difficult is it
to follow up that simple thought with
questions like how rapidly will rabbits
reproduce here what do rabbits eat what
animals are currently eating what the
rabbits are going to eat can these other
animals compete with
rabbits pretty easy questions that human
beings don't bother to ask instead we
think here's something I want and not
how is what I want going to affect
everything else and lead to
destruction what does this have to do
with the new atheists easy the new
atheists aren't deeper thinkers than
Thomas Austin they think I don't like
religion so let's get rid of it I like
atheism so let's get more of it and they
pay no no attention whatsoever to the
extremely complex web of connections
that they have just forever
altered the way ideas are connected in a
society is very similar to the way
organisms are connected in an ecosystem
and what's been happening in Western
Society over the past several decades as
every longstanding tradition or value is
attack is the ecological equivalent of a
forest
fire this destroying the religious and
moral framework is like a forest fire a
forest has trees and other plants birds
mammals insects and so on the forest
burns the trees which had been there for
decades or centuries and provided
stability to the
ecosystem
burn what replaces the trees that
burn whatever weeds spread most rapidly
again I'm really talking about ideas
when the ideas and values that have been
the Bedrock of your Society for
centuries are suddenly destroyed what
replaces
them whatever weeds spread most rapidly
so the new atheists really thought that
by setting their own forest on fire some
sort of Utopia was going to magically
emerge now they're staring at a bunch of
weeds they can't control wondering what
went
wrong second although it was rare some
of the new atheists did occasionally
think Beyond The Superficial me no like
Christianity so me get rid of it to
consider the possible ramifications of
getting rid of Christianity Richard
Dawkins of all people for many years has
been saying things like I have mixed
feelings about the decline of
Christianity in so far as Christianity
might be a Bull workk against something
worse he said that in
2010 in 2018 he warned in a tweet before
we Rejoice at the death throws of the
relatively benign Christian religion
let's not forget hair Bello's menacing
rhyme always keep a hold of nurse for
fear of finding something
worse so Dawkins recognized that
Christianity may be doing something in
society that's protecting people even
atheists from something even worse than
that terrible thing called
Christianity but that never stopped him
from blasting away at Christianity and
now Western nations are in a competition
to see how much worse worse can get the
most glaring worse is Islam which
Western Nations seem completely
incapable of stopping after Christians
kept stopping it for 14
centuries so while the new atheists
claim that they've been ridding the
world of superstition they've really
been Paving the way for the spread of
Islam and people are starting to
notice third the new atheism made some
testable predictions we're now in a
position to test those predictions and
they didn't come
true what did the new atheists predict
since Christianity is an obstacle to
progress and science getting rid of
Christianity will lead to progress and
more science replacing Christianity with
atheism will make people more rational
more scientific more noble people
becoming atheists will make Society
better let me ask how is any Western
nation better in any way thanks to the
new
atheism have Western Nations become more
rational more scientific more
noble no Western Nations are going
completely
insane millions of people becoming
atheists didn't get us one step closer
to a scientific Utopia but it got us 487
steps closer to a psychotic
dystopia so that's why the new atheism
has lost its momentum superficial
thinking Paving the way for Islam and
failed predictions now I mentioned
earlier that the epic failures of the
new atheism give us the materials for
two new arguments against atheism we
might call one the argument from
inadequacy or the argument from
ineptitude or the argument from
incompetence after more than two decades
of massive cultural shifting towards
atheism it really seems that atheism is
completely incapable of sustaining a
society all atheism does is destabilize
a society so that the society is too
weak to stand against dangerous ideas
within that society and dangerous ideas
coming to that Society from
outside here one of you atheists might
respond but David even if atheism turns
out to be bad for society that doesn't
mean it's not
true not so fast the driving force
behind the new atheism was that religion
is bad for society it's harmful that's
what gave the new atheists their
momentum so what happens if atheism is
bad for society what if atheism is
harmful
if atheism is bad for society it's got
to go right I don't make the rules I
just enforce
them we might call the other argument
the argument from glaringly obvious
spiritual Rebellion again from an
atheistic perspective doesn't make much
sense to care a whole lot about what
other people believe unless it's harmful
to you or to society in other words this
person lives and dies as a Hindu this
person lives and dies as a Muslim this
person lives and dies as a Christian
this person lives and dies as an
atheist from an atheistic perspective
what does it
matter why would you be obsessed with
what other people believe unless it's
harming you or it's harming
Society it makes no sense so what
happens when you find out that something
is actually good for you that it's
actually protect protecting you that
it's actually protecting your
society and you attack It
Anyway take Richard Dawkins for instance
Dawkins does not like Christianity but
Dawkins has understood for a very long
time that Christianity possesses some
sort of ability to protect a society
from worse
things and what does Dawkins do he
attacks Christianity removing the bull
workk until he's overwhelmed by the
worst things does that make any sense
whatsoever let's get more specific in
his discussion with Ayan hery Ali about
her conversion to Christianity Ali said
that she was so empty and depressed as
an atheist she didn't want to live and
she said that becoming a Christian made
her want to live again I lived for about
a decade with intense depression and
anxiety self-loathing I hit rock bottom
I went to a place where I actually
didn't want to live anymore but wasn't
brave enough to take my own life and so
I was self-medicating having reached a
place where I had absolutely nothing to
lose I prayed and I prayed desperately
and for me that was a turning point and
what happened after that is a miracle in
its own right I feel connected to
something higher and greater than myself
I
feel my zest for life is back Dawkins
heard his friend explain how
Christianity gave her back her zest for
Life naturally he responded by telling
her how stupid Christianity is this is
all obvious
nonsense this is all theological bull
now think about this they're friends
Ayan hery Ali is friends with Richard
Dawkins imagine your friend saying I was
depressed and I didn't want to live
until I believed in such and such now
I'm
happy would your instant reaction be to
attack belief in such and such knowing
that it's the only thing keeping your
friend from massive
depression let's change the example so
that it's something we would all regard
as silly suppose you find your best
friend on the ledge of a building you
say what are you
doing she says well I was so miserable
that I was about to jump but then I saw
this Crystal by my feet and I instantly
knew that it's a magic Crystal that
gives me the power to keep going as long
as I believe in the power of this magic
Crystal I'll always be happy
would it make sense as an atheist to say
to your friend what are you stupid there
are no magic crystals get rid of that
dumb rock you
idiot wouldn't you instead say to
yourself H I think believing in magic
crystals is really dumb but if my
friend's belief is somehow keeping her
alive right now I need to keep my mouth
shut until I have a way of successfully
replacing that Crystal with something
else that can keep her happy so if
something you think is stupid a magical
Crystal or Christianity is somehow
serving as a bullwark against something
bad your friend jumping off a building
or your Society being subjugated it
makes no sense at all to attack the bull
workk until you come up with something
else that can be the bull
workk but you have tons of atheists who
realize that even though they don't like
Christianity and don't believe in
Christianity Christianity is somehow a
Bull workk against worse things and yet
they can't stop attacking
Christianity it's as if atheists are
saying yes if we get rid of Christianity
we're inevitably going to be subjugated
by Islam or communism but you know what
totally worth
it we would rather be violently
subjugated than be surrounded by
Christians
and when you're that desperate to get
Jesus as far away from you as possible
even though belief in Jesus should be
irrelevant to you unless it's hurting
you kind of seems like a real problem is
with Jesus rather than with religion or
ideas you
reject the takeaway here is that some of
you atheists the ones who would gladly
watch your Society burn to the ground if
it meant you'd never have to hear about
Jesus it really looks like you're in a
kind of spiritual Rebellion against
Jesus which is what Christians have been
saying all
along thanks for the
cosign so that's where atheism is at
right now what's the future of atheism
well the new atheists made a bunch of
promises they couldn't keep they made a
bunch of predictions that didn't come
true Western Society may never fully
recover from the Damage Done over the
past two decades by atheists whose ideas
spread like rabbits or like a forest
fire choose your
analogy future Generations will look
back on the new atheism as a
catastrophic failure from now on when
atheists say you know it would make the
world a better place if we all became
atheists the response is going to be my
goodness just shut up you clowns have no
idea how to improve prove the world if
you want to be an atheist then be an
atheist but don't pretend that you have
the slightest clue how to make the world
a better place we gave you the chance
and you did irreparable
harm atheists will never again be taken
seriously when they start babbling about
their scientific
Utopia as for people who are atheists
now there are three main paths they can
take first some atheists are going to
leave atheism they're going to say I
tried atheism once the brief feeling of
superiority wore off it left me empty
and it did nothing to improve the world
so I'm out of here second there will be
atheists Who Remain atheists but they're
going to calm down they're not going to
be Evangelical about their atheism
they're going to return to the way
atheists were before the new atheism
they won't care much what other people
believe as long as it's not hurting
them third there will be atheists who
try to bring back the Glory Days of the
New atheism it felt good going around
saying we're smart we love science
everyone else is a religi
tart you can teach any on the
planet how to play skeptic and run
around screaming that's no evidence you
can't prove that to me you can't prove
that and it makes people feel good makes
people feel smart makes people feel like
they're better than
others there are atheists who don't want
to lose those feelings so they'll keep
trying to revive the movement it won't
work but we're about to see some amazing
cries for attention and some amazing
displays of
desperation what does that mean for the
future of atheism well if some atheist
are going to leave atheism and the
atheist to try to revive the Glory Days
are going to sound as sad as a
50-year-old who can't stop talking about
what a great quarterback he was when he
peaked in high school the only
respectable form of atheism will be the
non-aggressive atheism we remember from
the
1980s that's my prediction the gremlin
is going to turn back into a
mugai what are your predictions for the
future of of atheism share them now in
the comment section so we can test them
in the future just like we tested the
predictions of the new
atheists hopefully our predictions
unlike the predictions of the new
atheists won't leave us looking shallow
sloppy and gullible
[Music]